ces deux manceaux pays où le fossé gaz
intestinaux cesse de te servir de la
disparition de ton père pour excuser sa
mauvaise conduite meg et reviendra
jamais il ne faut pas perdre espoir
c'est son travail c'est quoi tous ces
calculs il pense qu'on peut voyager à
travers l'univers on tape la taille et
alors on réduit l'espace on prend un
raccourci
il doit vraiment manqué évidemment il
manque plus que tout au monde
et si on partait à sa recherche route
mon père avait raison c'est vraiment
possible
voici ma planète préféré de toute la
galaxie
qui êtes-vous
sommes à la recherche de combattants mon
père a accompli un exploit
extraordinaire mais il est peut-être en
engrais
mon père toujours en vie nous le pensons
et tu es la seule qui puisse le
retrouver
vous rigolez est ce que j'ai l'air de
rigoler un peu oui
et ben non je suis très sérieux
[Musique]
vous serez mis à l'épreuve
à chacun de vous ma crois en toi
et de ce fait ici
[Musique]
a new dance
cet endroit est dangereux
ne vous fiez pas aux apparences
je ne peux pas repartir sans mon père
des plus fortes que je ne vais jamais ce
test
[Musique]
à une guerrière sa confiance j'ai
confiance en toi
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]